I've never had a long-term relationship
but I think my main thing was the
frustration in the early periods that
that like quoting phase where you're
you're investing all this time you're
talking to her you're trying to keep her
attention and you know you're trying to
show you're this tough guy and you're
showing all these good tricks but you
also have to kind of convince her that
you need her and she's so fascinating
and she's a flame and she's gorgeous and
whatever and you gotta you've got to
kind of alter in between that was my
Challenge and then getting them out on
dates but once I get someone out on a
date it's pretty much done but the women
I on my roster are women that I don't
really have to do that for I just say
yeah you're pretty cool do you wanna you
wanna go to this like bowling alley
thing in shoreditch yeah cool and I
don't mind because for me I reward women
who are straightforward because that
shows respect in it if she's wasting
your time play games she doesn't respect
you what she's doing is she's creating
Hoops for you to jump through it's an
ego thing I'm smart yeah I know exactly
what you're doing
who are you feeling the goals I mess
with have to be intelligent because
intelligent women don't need to be
convinced and manipulated they don't do
hints
no she knows what she wants she's
educated she's not dumb she's not out
here I'm in an orange she knows who I am
I don't have to be Mr Alpha with the
gold belt I come in I'm humble I talk
some [ __ ] I'm a bit goofy but she knows
she understands that anyone who tried to
touch me would probably die in it fact
you're just not strong you're not
athletic you're not more athletic than
me you don't have better contact you
don't have a better job you're not
slicker than me but I don't have to show
that to you in it because showing things
attracts people who look and surface
things and they are chaotic the worst
women you can [ __ ] with are the chaotic
ones because they were [ __ ] all over
your life
that's the worst thing you could [ __ ]
do that would affect your job that will
affect your friendships should be
buzzing up your phone she'll be talking
[ __ ] about you to other guys for sex why
would you why would you and you have to
work for that as well can I ask you
something you said yeah yeah so one I I
want to ask you two things one right so
first you just said that like you don't
deal with women that play games but
wasn't that thing on your board just
like literally your game plan
it's the structure in our approach from
it it's not a game it's a strategy I
would consider it a game that's why I
would block him because I hate games
yeah but I wouldn't chat to you anyway
so you need to stop saying that the
women on your roster I know right I'm
wondering who's triggered here the woman
on your roster
about how you're gonna block me I
definitely I'm not triggered there's
been so many things
are dry there's so many things here that
could have triggered me but out there in
Windsor it's cold alone you were telling
me before you go to the show you're a
triggered
oh my God
triggered me no I didn't I said that you
say some irresponsible things
did you say some irresponsible thing
anyway no mental state is like the
Doctor Strange World you know where the
mirrors come out and things start
floating
[Music]
I'm so used to insecure people taking
shots so it's all good it's not a shot
anyways the second thing I wanted to ask
is any of those women on your roster are
any of them like women that you would
consider like serious or marriage
potential and if not why are they still
there what are you what do you date for
um
I guess I would consider some some of
them I have no intentions of settling
down right now so that that like that's
already built in
um but what I dig for is just to have
great seductive encounters with people I
think you can have a lady or woman who
behaves properly and is intelligent and
who generally adds value just by being
feminine and and pleasant and you know
we can hang out and spend some nights
together watching movies and going out
to bowling alleys and doing all the
things you do for fun we can do it in a
respectful way you know she can she'll
pay for some I'll pay for some sometimes
I want to treat her for a birthday I
took one girl out paid paid for like you
know the five stars whatever kind of
dinner and that's fine once in a while
25 pounds
doesn't she know that it's not serious
though yeah she knows we was more like a
[ __ ] buddy than anything he leaves the
girls in their mid-20s alone yeah yeah
oh my gosh too
he just started dating a 27 year old
yeah
granted it's Bella Hadid so it's like oh
you know what yeah
yeah
um
on your point you said a minute ago that
this strategy that you class as a game
that you said is the reason why you
don't go near me right guys you paid you
said guys you guys who play this game
you don't go in it the true for the
matter is I I may not be talking about
you specifically but generally right
you women are more susceptible to that
strategy and you don't even know
probably probably yeah probably I I yeah
probably well I kind of realized that
that whole ignore thing for attention
and stuff like that yeah and it really
puts me off yeah can I can I also just
say have your time and I'll just say do
you know the amount of the amount of
women I know who've just said what you
said who completely fall victim to it
hence why I said earlier what you say
you want what you respond to in real
life two completely different things I
can say that as a fact I've experienced
that well um if this show is popular
enough dudes I have blocked and they
will confirm it's fun
I'm gonna Read Super chats for a second
thank you Alex for the lovely
presentations
I think that's the most the most a guest
has ever brought to a show
so we there's gonna be a lot so I'm just
if anyone has any issues with what's
said hold it till the end hold it till
the end because there's a lot it's not
coming from me okay Jonathan Farley I
would like to court previous guests like
Alicia or the Zimbabwe girl since you
didn't reply to my 44 Page Letter I
assume you're not interested can paying
members pass letters along to them
you sent someone a 44-page letter from
my show that's a book
okay I'll
I honestly think Myrtle Myrtle you Urkel
is trolling there's no way she should be
this dumb unless she's mentally slow big
Breezy girl in the blue isn't as laying
as her free friends Matt butcher blue
turtleneck is creating her new identity
on the Fly being very defensive for some
reason
um Andrea n21 never made a bad decision
delusional Joshua I can't ever imagine
the girl in the blue is Raising anyone's
children with her Outlook Almighty Tien
Myrtle you're cool is a complete clown
Lawrence Bullock only traditional women
that are virtuous deserve to be courted
Christian s Camilla she thinks she's
special Eddie e curly hair in the middle
you are fine from the front and the back
drop your socials jbfm101
[Laughter]
the one in the Blues are clear repeat
victim of step three
um
yo yo fight the algorithm Fight The
Matrix you are pearly Neo and Sarah
morphis and Jess keep it going Guys Mt
modern women are feminists there isn't
isn't a feminine one among them hot ice
most of you left out that courtship has
always been for the purpose of exploring
the possibility of marriage Urban
politics in reality your ho froms became
single mothers despite searching for
some simp to come save them from
themselves pikas as a man I would rather
be my be on my own than with a 40 year
old with 12 kids no matter how great the
hands of the no matter how great the
years of hands-on experience makes her
in the sack Maverick
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible